No longer on the front lines.
Anton recounts
how he ended up a prisoner of war.
Okay.
Back in Russia,
he was behind bars
for the third time for drug
But also, he called me up.
I said,
when they put me in prison,
I heard they were recruiting,
served six months and they.
Pardon you tells me.
What a lawyer.
So he signed up with Stormzy,
a unit made up of convicts
attached to the Russian Defense Ministry
after only two weeks of basic training,
he was shipped off to the front lines
near Bermuda.
But
after days of intense shelling,
no food and only rainwater to drink.
He heard
Ukrainian troops outside his foxhole.
He assumed they would execute the other.
Want to shoot?
Yeah, I thought that was the end,
he recalls.
I switched my rifle to single shot mode
and thought, I'll shoot myself.
But I couldn't
Posada.
This video was shot
by soldiers
of Ukraine's
third assault
brigade shows the tense moments
when Anton and his comrade
Slava surrendered.
The Ukrainian troops told them.
Unlike Russians, we don't kill prisoners.
Vice, you would throw target
We spoke to Anton, Slava
and another soldier
in a makeshift jail in eastern Ukraine,
concealing their faces
and not using their real names.
The third assault brigade
granted us access to the P.O.W.s,
and two of their soldiers
were in the room for the interviews.
The P.O.W.s will soon be transferred
to Ukrainian intelligence.
They didn't appear to be under duress
and agreed to share their stories.
Slava, also serving time for drugs, said
conditions in the trenches were grim
as proclaiming food was scarce.
We didn't have medical kits, he says.
His commanders
took all the painkillers to get high,
he recalled.
And as a result, issued
nonsensical orders.
Morale was terrible.
Okay, sorry.
Sergei was wounded by a grenade
before surrendering to Ukrainian troops.
He was a contract soldier, not a convict.
He completed his six month
contract in Arizona and went home.
But when he hesitated
to sign another contract,
a military prosecutor gave him a choice.
Prison or back to the front yard.
He ended up outside parliament
under constant Ukrainian fire.
Discipline collapsed.
The officers fled
All illusions were shattered.
Straw.
It was very different
from what I saw on TV.
A parallel reality, says Cindy.
I felt fear,
pain and disappointment in my commanders.
But a law passed last year and Russia
imposed sentences of three to ten years
for soldiers who surrender voluntarily.
So if he returns home
in a prisoner exchange,
Anton may end up again.
Back in a Russian prison. He was released
many, like
Slava and Anton, are barely soldiers.
They were hardly trained,
poorly led, poorly supplied.
They were, to put it crudely.
The meat in Russia's meat grinder
in the battle of bath mud.
Now, the
Ukrainians say that they are making slow
but steady gains there,
but they are running into
very stiff resistance.
The report,
the Russians have reportedly poured
50,000 troops
into the defense of that town,
many of whom will probably end up
in the meat grinder Jake.
Remarkable reporting from CNN's Ben
Wedeman in eastern Ukraine.
Thank you so much.
CNN is also on the ground
in Belarus, a close ally of Russia,
and now apparently
in the home of Wagner, mercenary
warlord Yevgeny Prigozhin
after his short
lived a largely unchallenged mutiny
in Russia last week.
It was Ill-Fated, of course.
Belarus's leader,
Alexander Lukashenko,
was not shy about his role in ending
Wagner and promotions rebellion.
Lukashenko's claimed
he was able to successfully negotiate
with Prigozhin
when the Wagner boss refused to pick up
Putin's phone calls.
Let's get right to CNN's
Matthew Chance, who is in Minsk.
And Matthew,
what's the latest on the Putin
Lukashenko relationship?
Are they still tight
Well, I
mean, it's a fascinating relationship,
but it's you know, it's pretty
one sided in the sense
that, you know, when Putin
asks for something to be done
Lukashenko is what it looks like
from the outside.
Lukashenko just goes ahead and does it.
Putin wanted to use Belarus
as a launching pad.
One of the launching pad
for his invasion of Ukraine in 20, 21.
Lukashenko agreed
Putin wanted nuclear weapons
to be stationed in this country.
So that he could threaten the West
even further. Lukashenko agreed.
And when there was that
military uprising, that attempted coup,
as it's been described in Russia
by Wagner
mercenaries of their leader,
Yevgeny Prigozhin, what was it last week?
Well, you know, Lukashenko stepped in
and invited Wagner and Prigozhin
to come and live over here.
The Kremlin announced.
All of those things, of course.
But Lukashenko says this was all him.
This is all him showing
what an independent
you know,
free kind of agency is
operating in this region.
But the fact is, is heavily
indebted to Russia.
So he owes them
a lot of money, more money
than any other country in the world.
He's isolated internationally
because of his own terrible
human rights record.
And those things are pushing
Belarus more and more into
the arms of the Kremlin Jake.
CNN's Matthew Chance in Belarus,
thank you so much.
Joining us now to discuss, retired U.S.
Army Brigadier General Peter Zweig.
He served as a senior U.S.
defense attache to Russia.
Also with us in studio, Beth
Sander, former
deputy director of National Intelligence.
General, so let me start with you
back to what
we just heard in that incredible
Ben Wedeman report
at the top of the hour.
One of the P.O.W.s
accused the Russian commanders
of being high all the time on painkillers
and giving at times
nonsensical orders understandably,
this led to very low morale,
according to this P.O.W..
Do you think that's true?
Does that comport
with other intelligence that we've heard?
And what can you do to capitalize
on any low morale
Good evening, Jake, viewers.
War is hell at any level,
especially in the trenches,
especially when you're coerced to fight.
And that we're getting
we've been getting all
since the beginning of the invasion
last year.
Most of the Russian forces on the ground
and that would be young
soldiers and junior or mid-grade officers
are absolutely living hell down there.
And the coercion and the and the
and the storm units and everything else.
So, yes, I do believe whether it's pills
or drinking, lots of drinking,
that those reports, the things
go on at that low level
where discipline
is on the edge,
which we've been reading for
quite some time.
It is completely feasible.
The troops,
I don't think, have any faith
in their leadership.
The only thing they're fighting for at
that level
I believe, is for
their own lives
and for their foxhole buddies.
But they're not fighting
for the regime
and and guinea pigs and brought that out.
So, no, this is this is a real corrosion
erosion within the Russian ranks.
The I don't know
what the breaking point is,
but it's it's there.
And now they're going to put in so-called
another 180,000 that big number.
Well, a lot of them
certainly do not want to come.
If this is true
and I think we just have to sort of
stand by so that Beth-center is
is already the situation before
the Virginia Ocean attempted rebellion.
And you've said that
the rings of implication
from that attempted
mutiny will spread very wide
now that we're
more than a week out from it.
How do you see Putin's grip on power
and his reliance
on the leader of Belarus,
Alexander Lukashenko?
Well, I actually don't think
that his grip on power in the very near
term is shaken
as much as a lot of commentators say.
I think more about the ring's
being more unstable
the closer you get into the elites
the more firm it is for the time being.
And the reason being is
because those elites depend
on Putin and Putin's reign right.
And so he put his cards in with Shoigu
and the military and now the military.
Those people owe him even more.
So while there were a few bad
apples, certainly, what did Putin do?
He raised the pay of the military.
He held a ceremony
giving them false thanks.
Right.
Because they didn't
help out during the mutiny.
But he held this big ceremony
saying how great they were.
He's trying to keep those
people together.
So I actually think that
in the near term, I think that Putin
isn't that much weaker.
Hmm.
And then
Russian state
media reports
Ukrainian shelling
has killed
one person and injured 40,
including children in Donetsk.
Russian occupied territory,
damaging kindergartens,
medical facilities, apartments.
That's what Russia says, Ukraine says.
They destroyed a Russian military base
when it comes to this
sort of like competing claims.
Do you just automatically discount
what the Kremlin says
because they've lied
about so many things,
including whether or not
they were going to invade Ukraine?
Well, a lot of times
Russia says
exactly what you would
expect them to say.
You know,
they're always going
to be blaming the other side
and they're always going to be
trying these false flags,
for example,
on this Operation
Nuclear plant, them
saying that the Ukrainians
are about to attack
could be a cover
for what they do themselves. So.
So they're always trying to change
that perception
of their own people in particular,
they don't want to be seen as butchers.
Yeah.
All right.
Beth Sander and Brigadier General
Peter Black,
thanks to both of you for your expertize.
Appreciate it.